[Music]
clouded corner Dave okay remember when
we were a superhero team surprisingly no
yeah you think we'd remember something
like that you mean you have no
recollection when a meteor smashed into
Earth gave us incredible powers forming
the 300 be adequately impressive three
and then we just stand around and watch
daredevil on Netflix yeah the clips
helped us remember why didn't we do
anything after that well we did have
that unpleasant encounter with the
Silver Surfer yeah but that was so bad
that everyone forgot it as a shit but
maybe we forgotten what it means to be
superheroes okay what do you mean what
if we did it again what if we brought
back the adequately impressive three
only this time but we did it right Oh
darker grittier and more realistic which
as we all know immediately equals better
no more pixel later Club Aurora or
sparky-sparky boom man
together we shall be Malcolm Tamara and
this sounds a critic
wait what happened or superiority we're
to entry for them we don't need them
anymore and together we shall become
oh I see you look a title displayer name
so we would have to say it out loud
exactly that's really embracing our
brand with pride and enough of this
bright colorful background hey we're in
a dark room our lives our dark room one
big dark room my god critic this is so
different what are we going to do with
the new us this time we're going to get
it right
we're going to sit around and watch
Jessica Jones on Netflix it's just a
metaphor for something oh how are you
guys still not fighting crime quite
wrong daizy were brooding just doing the
same thing you did last time
no we're doing it in a darker room look
just because just because you're doing
the same thing in a dark room does not
mean you're still mad during the same
time of course it does seem dark and
unpleasant always equals more
sophisticated and faithful just look at
the original source material doesn't it
just scream dark blues and gritty
realism I think somebody needs to read a
comic let me guess you just saw the last
cinematic version of Fantastic Four no
just all the lesson imagine a fanboys
deck
[Music]
Fox's disaster his reboot at the
Fantastic Four franchise was not only a
critical audience and box-office portal
suck but even the director expressed his
disappointment on Twitter before the
film came out man there's ouch and then
there's this would be the fourth time
the Fantastic Four was bought
cinematically and it said there was such
an impressive amount of failures the
most accurate representation is this one
1:32 what are you doing yeah they get
that bad so while you focus on what's
most important perfecting your brooding
pose get off of me I'll start the review
this is fantastic for zoom opens with
the Fox logo flashing the letter F
similar to how they flash the letter X
before the x-men films honestly you want
to give us any assurance you quash this
we see a young Reed Richards getting
distracted by a scientific idea at
school don't you know American high
schools where ideas go to die
earth to Richards email sky Star Trek
jokes always wins over an entire class
we see it's teacher Homer Simpson not
really that's his voice actor dan
Castellaneta random it's not happy with
his future goals I want to be the first
person in human history to teleport
himself it's already possible to
transport quantum information from one
location to another even if you could
build a thing I've already built it I am
also working on a foolproof way to keep
a PD out of my room the assignment was
to pick a real career in the real world
where can't you be a nuclear safety
engineer or an astronaut for mayor or
country singer manager I can keep going
I've had over 188 jobs you think your
friendship is running on fumes cute but
his friend Ben also seems to be having
trouble when he goes home to it
dysfunctional family hey Claude Rains
huh what do you think yeah that
light-hearted phrases from an abusive
household whoa a read says you can get
him out of this movie I mean situation
he just needs a power converter for his
points capacitor I mean remake of
explorers I mean teleporter actually
what's capacitor was have more
reasonable at this point
don't blow up
ah what every producer said when this
movie premiered holy smokes I made weed
we are going to be the Fantastic Four
twenty years go by and the two are ready
to try their experiment again at the
science fair it modulates the frequency
of matter from one location to another
and back again much because you're
seeing the word things again it's a
teleporter
yeah whatever nerd what are you very
stretcher ready may want to cover your
ears the experiment makes the teleport
to a location they're not sure of so
there's no proof it actually teleported
but it does result in a sonic boom so
powerful destroyed the basketball hoop
so hey that's got to count for something
you're disqualified wait what wait what
this is a science fair not a magic
competition so magic destroyed the
basketball hoop geez well Chris you
homework
your only transports matter hmm
well thank God the director of a
government-sponsored research institute
working on interdimensional
teleportation just happened to be there
no really so almost done eating Lucky's
pubes to have that happen
I think you've cracked interdimensional
travel we're from the backs of
foundations we'd like to give you a full
scholarship I was going to give a
grandpa NAT paper mache volcano but I
guess this is a little better they take
it to a school so high-tech they can't
fully light their hallways as retries to
get friendly with the directors daughter
Sue Storm so you like music is that kind
of like your thing
oddly enough no what sounds that for
melodies essential thing there's
patterns in everything anything
what's one you want to be famous am i
that predictable well when you're in
this movie it's hard not to be it's like
a Victor Von Doom is on here yep you
heard that correctly this dark gritty
realistic version still has a guy named
Von Doom in it because professor von
evil nasty wasn't obvious enough
nevertheless storm is still convinced he
should be brought on to the project so
someone stole my design
no one stole anything Victor bullshit
you know Borat and Peter Dinklage stole
my face
how will you make a joke about it later
I'm sorry
Moret figure seeing how our box office
will be on par with bruno who's that
thank you
who's Victor and why did I notice and
when literally nothing makes him stand
out at all even the shot has been
composed so that you'll focus on him I'm
more likely to think this guy is Victor
this is our melon folks even the movie
forgets he's supposed to be important
rudimentary think you see images that
open the parallel dimension that they're
trying to get to it's beautiful you can
tell by the investment in my voice they
hope this new world can save our current
one as I'm assuming earth is being
drained of its color by FBI's most
wanted terrorists it's a whole new world
which should help save this one not that
it deserves to be saved after Jim over
here I don't even know how to take that
was he making a joke or just calling him
by his name it's like calling your bad
guy doctor you're a monster there just
be some confusion down the road but it
turns out storm has another son named
Johnny who's a reckless troublemaker in
this scene he is literally never
reckless or causes trouble throughout
the rest of the film well you're not
getting the car back excuse me you're
gonna have to earn you gonna have to
come work for me I'm not wearing a lab
coat so Johnny joins a world-changing
experiment to get his car back because
you know life and is reintroduced to the
team is that Adolf long time you don't
need to make fun of his name it does it
quite naturally on its own they have
their little making stuff montage
complete with do to do to music
[Music]
and it appears they've made a lot of
progress so I gotta say it's fun having
you here uh did we miss that part not
kidding there has never been one moment
of any of these characters smiling
except for one shot in the montage where
they're eating and not saying a word to
each other is the movies idea of
building chemistry literally building
chemistry look don't get used to this
I'm just here taking my car back you
don't understand we had Chinese food and
dude to do music ladies and gentlemen
that was our first action scene the time
has come to test the portal on an
unrendered model from Space Chimps they
would have used a real monkey but
apparently sitting in a chair was too
dangerous and it seems to be successful
but it turns out they don't want to use
the inventors for the first human
teleports doesn't it go without saying
we have to start thinking about sending
Matt us I think it's time to start
coordinating with our friends at NASA
hey thank you the shuttle to the moon
wasn't invented by Neil Armstrong they
even make a reference to that later guys
know who built the Apollo spacecraft
went to the moon but you know Neil
Armstrong is right yeah exactly so why
did you think you were going unless we
go first
why don't we go first oh god this thing
works I guess let's go up a
history-making experiment for your egos
I'm sure this will in no wait you know a
hold on us I can try I had to get out
just once I'm sure this will in no way
muck everything up but in order to
destroy everything they worked for our
three scientists need one more to go
with them
clowns sure you're all thinking the same
brilliant mine who has such a big impact
then Ben because you know why the hell
not he has no scientific mind done
literally nothing and out of himself as
so useless that he just left read before
they even started building it yeah I
don't know if it just going to school
here looks like a home buddy so okay
apartment should be him I need you to
come because we're going tonight I told
the guys I'm not going
about you okay who's gonna have my back
oh yeah broom handle arms is really
gonna be trouble for any danger out
there surely he must be drunk you drunk
yeah I'm a little drunk
evil reason to do it what bins the moon
landing go this way Justin I'm so
plastered and I know one six I just
worked really hard on this and
everything but my buddy oh that junkyard
couldn't protect me to save either of
our lives and bros before hos
scientifically this has to be done Hey
look man Troy let's go give it a chance
so they travel to this new dimension to
discover it's just as dark and bland as
our world it's amazing we did it don't
you dare take off your sub-zero mask if
we come across a reptile in this out
world go we want evenly matched but
here's something I bet you never thought
they would come across in this movie
something yeah goddamn something either
you thought they would never get to that
in this film my god Mountain Dew is
working on another new flavor but don't
let it touch you hormones of all drinkin
Victor gets left behind bun is covered
in Cadbury eggs and Sue despite not
being there somehow gets affected as
well sorry babe it's one small step for
man you just get our gamma farts life is
fair in terms of read can now stretch
incredibly far I dare even say we call
him mr. fantastic nothing hot not just
kidding
does that be just like a comic book
[Music]
wait the origin story for Flame Princess
is a lot more intense I thought it'd be
so of course gets invisible powers and
that looks like an uneven rockbiter
cheeto wait what what happened to me I
don't know but I'm going to figure this
out and by comeback I mean abandoned you
not help you in any way you never return
this is a complicated love
[Applause]
you
[Music]
Hey look at dark room I haven't seen
that yet where is creased reads gone you
want to find a cure we have resources
here okay so this is particularly
interesting we just got done with the
scene showing pretty much what bin looks
like a cookie Church shit out by the
rock monster from Galaxy Quest if for
some reason they keep this identity a
secret here even though we clearly
already know what he looks like
sometimes being dark have already been
pretty pointless but this Gordy found a
black hole of pointless like there's
already no point and yet somehow it
creates even less of a point its until
there's a cold on me all around an
interesting dark blur for to make things
even stranger we're almost at the one
hour mark and only now have they changed
into their hero forms most of them just
woke up and suddenly it's one year later
Ben is fighting for the army johnny has
just figured out how to shoot fireballs
soo can turn yourself and other things
invisible while also creating forcefield
and they want to harness this power so
they can go back to the parallels I
mentioned to get even more powers now
you think I'm paraphrasing there what to
take maybe a minute for me to say it
takes the movie the exact same amount of
time to get all that information at you
yeah most of the superhero stuff is done
in one goddamn minute and it's not even
in the forefront seedbed doing all this
cool action stuff well it's not nearly
as exciting as watching it in a distance
with a bunch of lifeless douchebag
sitting around we finally get some
frickin action and it's not even the
focus what how would you like it if an
action scene in the Dark Knight was from
a distance being watched by somebody
else
he's you're talking mister fuck oh fuck
oh is that Batman fighting the Joker yes
is that somehow being less dramatic you
hmm
you're quite right oh please ah much
better
the Pacific now this is exciting
but don't worry if this is too much out
of your comfort zone see or not we go
right back into talking in dark rooms
again what if it takes more time to get
it right we could be talking years I am
NOT going to be a tool the movie
strongly disagrees but it looks like
reid has been missing for a year - yeah
sure is hard to track a butt naked
scientist with no military training
however he's eventually found by the
army who bring Bennet what God bit so
thick before you've been hiding now
hey where's your thing hide yourself a
good name okay finally we're gonna get
some action that was short oh wait wait
wait wait out of the magnitude of
variety we've had in the film so far let
me take a guess a wild goddamn guess
what coming up next
Oh God but what's a wife a fantastic
wife isn't that your god damn movies
it's called Fantastic Four and you can't
even get one fantastic thing it is why
are you talking in a goddamn darkroom
fantastic what did you have it
upbringing like the boy from room is
this literally oh you know what's the
outside when we explained to you in
pictures and stories and so could you
tell one of those dozens more
interesting that are set well and
outside seem to take it away better do
you ever wonder what life would have
been like if you hadn't come to the
science fair that day we could have been
sitting in a dark room with table lamps
the table lamps Green is back we're
closer than we've ever been before
closer to would the end credits we can
finally start real movies again they
return to Planet Burt brownie where they
discover Doom is alive and well hey
trust me as long as this movie still
going doom will always be alive and well
you want to know how I survived that
place gave me strength okay I know it's
a comic book adaptation there have to be
some changes but what is with Fox's
obsession of turning Marvel characters
and just let that crash test dummies
it's this the one design they think
exists it's getting a little old hell
you'll remember that interesting to
begin with but smoking really is the
master of throwing boring uninteresting
things at you in a movie that's called
fantastic right what do you think their
design for the climax is that we can
port off the sky question
nostalgia critic style D critic do you
remember Titan mr. critic looking spring
soon and the audience will be impossible
birds will be nesting in the hazel
thicket and they'll be sowing the summer
barley in the lower fields meaning the
first of the strawberries with cream to
remember that is to struggle this over
huh we can't recall the taste of fruity
or the sound of originality I'm making
in the dark you a dark room just talking
and talking doing nothing the talking a
cliche and portal staring at me I can
see it with my for all dyes then let us
be rid of it once a bar I can born a
cliche mr. critic but I can carry you
Oh or you know you can just finish the
damn review hey I guess that's an option
this was owned this is weird but what we
just did right here that little bit so
you might be wondering where the hell
did this destroy the world things
suddenly come from especially from a guy
with such a cuddly name like doom well
I'll give this movie some credit instead
of having a huge exposition dump in one
minute like before this movie gives us
at least 20 seconds more yep in that
short amount of time he says that his
life cycle is tied to that world that he
believes our world would destroy and so
he wants to destroy ours before I can
get the jump on his world and who cares
thank you clip from the obscure movie
screwed you're right moving on
it looks like Professor Storm gets
murdered allegis looks weird without a
Jim Carrey song number going on and our
hero sorry it was only two syllables and
I still couldn't say it our these guys
tried to stop him from sucking the world
into his dimensional bullshit
but Victor is too powerful and figures
out ways to stop all of them Victor
don't do this there is no picture I'm
not wasting the clip on you but the
Fantastic Four eventually get the drop
on it time yeah and the context of the
movie that line really should be what my
brother said before he beat me up still
liking relevant day we did whatever we
did would like to continue our existing
relationship we don't need you or
anybody else to keep an eye on us
we just want a place where we can work
and what if we say no say yes how much
space are we talking again I am actually
so disinterested in what's going on I am
actually more curious and who told how
many rolls from that plate okay only
Johnny seemed to take one he apparently
didn't finish it the others had coffee
but nobody tried their water
dude that guy was on fire I think you
would at least have some water being on
the biggest concerns I'm pulling out of
this movie with so they're given their
own location to continue to test out
their powers because the Lord knows we
haven't seen enough of that in these
movies as they seem to interact off each
other I think that the four of us should
have a name why would we need a name
because we're a team now and there's
four of us
so we should come up with a name for it
how about two guys a girl and the thing
that nobody wanted hey we both know that
you could take them Jesus I'm beginning
to see why you didn't give them
personalities their relationships to the
road was more interesting fantastic yes
it is
okay I got it up we didn't have to say
about well you still have to take a
movie with a guy named Von Doom
seriously piss off and that was Vance
Norris dick it's bad really bad the
other fantastic four movies fail too but
at least they fail in an over-the-top
way they at least try to embrace the
look and corniness of the comic it's
like it's ashamed to have anything to do
with Fantastic Four or comic books in
general in fact when you add them all
together
the Hammer film is still the only one
where they choose to fight crime and
they're not the ones who caused all the
destruction they're fighting against
what does that happen how that happen in
two reboots you're trying to make better
all I can say is there's a right way and
a wrong way to do dark gritty comic-book
material and this is definitely the
wrong way I'm the Nostalgia Critic and
I'm just done now I'm done guys this
movie took a lot out of me
okay now what are we supposed to do
[Music]
whoa Fox why would you let us play with
the Avengers in spider-man oh don't
worry we still have plans for you you
don't do you not a thing and you get to
suffer for it now continue being
anything but what you really are
flame on I think you mean like that
[Music]
[Applause]
Victor there is only doom
hey dub Walker here doing the charity
shout out and this week we are doing
LIVESTRONG this foundation fights to
improve the lives of people affected by
cancer created in 1997 the foundation is
known for leading an ongoing dialogue
with patients and survivors providing
free cancer support services and
advocating for policies that improve
access to care and quality of life
LIVESTRONG has become a symbol of hope
and inspiration around the world since
its inception the foundation has served
2.5 million people affected by the
disease and raised more than 500 million
dollars to support cancer survivors
being one of America's top nonprofit
organizations LIVESTRONG enjoys a four
star rating on Charity Navigator as been
recognized by the National Health
Council and the Better Business Bureau
for its excellent governance high
standards and transparency check out
their website and their YouTube channel
and you can see all the inspiring
stories and how you can play a major
part in one of them
you
[Music]